plutôt qu'un débat sémantique le chef de
l'état a mis presque trois ans à
trancher entre les mots comme le taris
mais séparatisme plutôt qu'un grand
discours
nous attendons les français attendent
des actes forts
il n'est que temps maintenant d'agir
beaucoup plus fortement sans faiblesse
ni naïveté contre l'idéologie de
l'islamisme politique est radical qui a
déjà conquis trop de territoire de notre
république qui sape les fondements de
notre démocratie qui construit partout
des écosystèmes islamistes nous familles
politiques de la droite républicaine
sommes pleinement engagés dans le combat
contre cette idéologie mortifère pour
notre république nous proposons d'écrire
dans notre constitution que nul individu
ou nuls groupe ne peut se prévaloir de
ses origines ou de ses croyances pour
s'exonérer du respect de la règle
commune
il n'est plus temps de discourir il est
temps d'agir
il faut un sursaut républicain
maintenant il y a quatre jours votre
ministre de la santé déclaré qu'elle ne
serait pas candidate à paris en raison
je la cite d'un agenda très chargé et
des nombreuses réformes dans son
ministère
quarante huit heures plus tard la voici
qui démissionne pour mener la campagne
du parti présidentiel dans la capitale
comment peut-on revenir à ce point sur
sa parole en à peine 48 heures en quoi
les dossiers du ministère de la santé
serait-il devenu soudainement si
secondaire cette candidature improvisé
imposée par le président de la
république en dit long sur le sens des
priorités et des responsabilités du
gouvernement être ministre du nouveau
monde n'empêche visiblement pas de faire
campagne pour les élections municipales
vous même monsieur le premier ministre
vous faites campagne war
doit-on comprendre que dans le nouveau
monde
on peut être ministre à temps partiel et
se présente à une élection tout en
annonçant à l'avancé que l'on ne siègera
pas comme maire la réforme des retraites
est sans doute la plus importante du
quinquennat
et pourtant les conditions de son examen
devant notre assemblée sont de loin les
plus chaotiques
tout a été organisé pour priver les
français da vrai débat parlementaire la
france insoumise est votre allié
objectif sur ce dossier car elle vous
permet de passer sous silence les
nombreuses lacunes de cette réforme
coûteuse injuste et inutilement complexe
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
vos noms choix conduiront à l'arrêt
définitif du premier réacteur de la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
cet événement démontre l'absence de
cohérence de votre stratégie énergétique
monsieur le premier ministre il ne
s'agit pas de faire de fessenheim un
symbole de l'incohérence populiste verte
de votre nom stratégie énergétique
il s'agit bien de compenser sérieusement
les effets d'une décision assassine pour
tout un territoire
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi
faire simple quand on peut faire
compliqué
c'est semble-t-il la devise du
gouvernement on en a la preuve avec le
débat sur les retraites
on en a aussi la preuve avec la question
de la prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir
d'achat
c'était simple et c'est est universel
pour reprendre un objectif qui devrait
vous plaire
mais c'était trop simple pour 2020 vous
avait conditionné cette prime à la
présence d'un accord d'intéressement
ça veut dire un document négocié entre
les chefs d'entreprise et les
représentants salariés qui engagent
l'entreprise sur plusieurs années et qui
répondent à des critères très exigeants
notre système de protection sociale et
de santé est assailli par des crises
persistantes
monsieur le ministre des usagers et les
soignants sont lassés des annonces les
plus technocratique successifs et ils
attendent aujourd'hui des actes
[Musique]